but let's talk about uh speaking of of
terrible families and abusers we have a
story about hunter biden
oh you're ready for conspiracy theory uh
uh conspiracy theories huh that aren't
conspiracy theories anymore because we
waited a couple months not even a couple
of months it's been a week yeah hunter
this is look at this hunter biden helped
secure funds for u.s bio lab contractor
in ukraine gosh
incredible
russia's assertion that biden's son
hunter was financing biological
laboratories and ukraine was based on
truth now hold on there a minute
bio weapons
i don't know anything about
and that's where the fact checkers keep
coming in because instead of saying bio
labs which we know exists now because
victoria nuland basically said they do
you say that and the media comes out and
says
they talked about bioweapons labs like
no no no these are bio threat reduction
labs the us is trying to stop the threat
of biological weapons and i've got to be
honest it actually makes sense
these programs the funding it all makes
sense that they're they're investing
they're doing research not on weapons
but they're doing research on pathogens
for the sake of being able to identify
and and protect against considering
they're right next to russia i think
that makes sense you can look at it more
from a more malicious or nefarious angle
and say no i don't trust the us they're
probably doing this well we still don't
have any evidence yeah i guess the
question is what kind of research do we
know they're doing there is gain of
function research occurring but we don't
know we don't know anything right right
check it out they say a trove of emails
on hunter biden's infamous laptop found
that he played a role in helping a
california defense contractor analyze
killer diseases and bioweapons in
ukraine now that is a bold statement i'm
going to push back a little bit and say
based on what i've read from this i
still don't see bioweapons but far be it
for me to call the new york post who is
news guard certified
wrong
if they're saying the emails show hunter
biden did this and there are other
outlets reporting the same thing then i
can only say i don't know look fact
checkers take it up with the new york
post i'm i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
say you know what it must be a
conspiracy it's all fake news so the new
york post and their conspiracy theories
why would they go and report that
the funny thing is the new york post
reported about hunter biden's laptop
what did they say russian disinformation
then we get the bio lab story what does
the media say russian disinformation you
give it a week what do you find it's all
true you know as soon as we first heard
that phrase i joked
why would we ever believe these people
when they call something russian
disinformation that's what they call
like everything that turns out to be
true and also why would we believe them
when they said anything about a
biological uh weapons lab being fake
news but it's both sides of the
political aisle now it's not just the
democrats saying russian disinformation
uh for example just last week
congressman dan crenshaw was on fox and
friends and rachel campos duffy was kind
of pushing him back saying hey some
republicans are concerned about you know
just jumping on the ukraine you know
bandwagon and giving them everything
they want because yeah we're worried
about pushing russia closer to china
whatever crenshaw goes well uh we're not
fun you know when they say you're
funding neo-nazis that's a lie it's
totally fake news and then he goes and
says the bio labs when you say the bio
labs you're playing into putin's hands
you're pushing russian disinformation
and this is a republican member of
congress and
obviously this came out two days ago
it's been vindicated and he has said
nothing these people say nothing they
lie and then when they get caught lying
they never apologize they never correct
their record in fact they double down
and so it's it's dangerous that we're
playing with a nuclear power uh like
this and i don't know are these people
working to protect the biden family are
they not wanting this information to
actually become the weirdest public but
i don't know the weirdest thing about
this
is that we have confirmation from
victoria newland testifying before the
senate there are biological research
facilities in ukraine or biolabs for
sure
as far as i know tulsi gabbard tucker
we're not talking about weapons now
truth be told i haven't heard every
single thing tucker said but tulsi she
came out she's like i never said weapons
there's bio labs there and we're like
russia might get us a bad thing like
what's going on there we should know so
they always move the word so after the
2020 election it went from there's no
there's no voter fraud there's no
widespread voter fraud right they always
move the word they always try to change
the narrative and they play a narrative
game and they can because they have big
tech on their side and they have every
mainstream media publication on their
side and so they can move whatever hell
word they want just to say that we're
wrong but i just i'm just what's
confusing to me is that when you wait a
week the story's proven true
so how are there people who still
believe this like a story breaks you
gotta go i'm gonna wait a week then you
go oh that's what happened huh but there
are people you know like like bill burr
you know when he was talking to joe
rogan and said i just turn the tv on
once every two weeks and do what they
tell me once every two weeks i turn it
on yeah they do whatever they say hey
look at that he's like no you know where
you know you're not a doctor you know
you're talking about masks why do you
become fouchy yeah
it's like it's like younger
yeah what are you talking about over
there talk about masks yeah but no um i
think that
maybe i'm being a little optimistic here
but the number of people believing them
are fewer and fewer with each passing
day let's uh let's let's ramp it up we
got the story from the wall street
journal prosecutors advanced tax probe
of hunter biden grand jury heard witness
in february about past drug use spending
habits of president sun let's talk about
ukraine hunter biden was helping secure
funding for this contractor it was
reported by several outlets uh notably
the daily mail that hunter biden and joe
biden shared bank accounts this was back
i think in september they reported this
so here you have joe biden whose son is
on the board of an energy company where
he doesn't have any experience or speak
the language
there's concerns about an investigation
of the founder of that company michael
zlatjevsky and then there are some
requests you know some emails go to
hunter about like we got to deal with
this then joe biden flies out and says
if you don't fire the prosecutor then
you're not getting the billion dollar
loan guarantee
sounds an awful lot like a lot to me
like joe biden uses his son as a proxy
for corrupt dealings in these countries
and you know what i feel bad for hunter
we keep ragging on hunter yeah he's just
a fall guy for biden right yeah joe
biden
it seems like he says to his son you go
work the private company you get the
salary i can set these deals up because
i'm the vice president we'll share bank
accounts you pay my bills and we'll have
one guy for all of our taxes that's what
they were that's what they were doing
it's been reported yeah the shared bank
accounts thing is a unbelievably
gigantic red flag to the point where you
don't you still share your bank account
with your dad yeah believe it or not i
don't know no no but if i was smoking
parmesan cheese maybe i would have to
for for people at this income level i
don't know how they shared a bank
account yeah because the taxes must have
been a nightmare
how would you prove to the irs that this
purchase is like oh well this one wasn't
joe this is hunter because you people
need to understand you can't just give
people money you cannot do that you're a
wealthy person making 83 000 a month
like like hunter biden he cannot just
hand 40 grand to his dad it's not legal
you'd have to do tax filing for like
gift taxes and stuff like that so that's
that that's that's a huge
red flag i mean i'm just confused by
what their system was today and it's
also important to know that it wasn't
just hunter and beau biden was also
involved in the family corruption and
nobody wants to talk about that because
obviously you know meat passed away and
that's that's that's tragic and that's
sad um but beau biden ran a foundation
and it just came out uh
sorry
uh but it just came out in a in a new
report that uh uh he he was in charge of
the foundation they raised like 4.9
million dollars only 500 thousand
dollars that actually went to operating
costs and the rest of the 4.4 4.5
million went to paying um you know
salaries of board members and lobbyists
and consultants and so it's a whole
family corruption it's it's a disgusting
family that's done nothing for our
country but used it to get rich do i
really have to clarify that saying i
feel bad for hunter was a joke
no i mean look pointing out this dad's
corrupt and and come on pushing all this
like no hunter biden's a bad guy to be
fair given the way his dad acts around
young children i am not convinced
terrible things didn't happen to hunter
biden so i do feel bad oh yeah yeah yeah
i mean
he's also a crackhead yeah we gotta keep
that in mind
crackheads make bad decisions they sure
do it's true though you know look look
and and with all due respect people
suffering from addiction who need help
they do make bad decisions regardless of
whether or not you want to have sympathy
form or not hunter biden man
you know it's really fascinating you see
these people of great power but they
just can't control themselves yeah
epstein
i mean that's why they seek power people
who can't control themselves try to
control the entire world to compensate
for that unfortunately i think in
politics i i talk about this a lot you
know i wasn't a perfect grade point
average student in high school i you
know i was a high school student that
particularly
in high school i yelled gay i tweeted
gay i was a i was a rebellious high
school student but i think a lot of the
folks that end up getting into
washington dc were the folks that never
were really popular in school were never
um
you know they were like the really great
students they didn't really have a lot
of fun and for the first time in their
lives they get into power they feel kind
of cool and then they
take off you know years and years of
misery and anger and then they do bad
things with it and so a lot of sick
people up in washington because i
believe yeah well joe biden was actually
uh very popular uh in high school he was
a very good football player it led to
him getting the nickname hands he called
him hands
he's got that do you remember there was
this whole story i think it was like a
children's thing but they they said that
joe biden's uh nickname in high school
was hands because he was so good at
football he was really good at catching
them something like that yeah
well i also heard that he was very
popular with the kids in the pool and
he's got hairy legs
i've heard that too
can you believe that story when he was
like i'd be in the pool and the kids
would grab my leg hairs like what are
you talking about 81 million people
voted for that
dude i i always tell the story of the
the people i knew who were like posting
on social media like i did my part
voting for joe biden did you and i'm
like
oh man
if only you watched true not a shock at
of pressure and batacaf care maybe maybe
but these people just they they just
i don't know where they get their
information from they're watching cnn
all day i guess because yeah cnn doesn't
have any ratings no they get it from
twitter unfortunately most of these
people get it from twitter and podcasts
and twitter recognizes that and that's
why they started to break the game and
they they promote you know it's it's
stuff like remember when covet happened
and then they had the trending tab and
the news tab and then they created a
whole separate covet 19 tab they're
basically doing the same thing with for
ukraine now they're just controlling the
narrative they're banking on people not
doing their research and twitter has
become the the thought box for almost
half the country if not more now thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and we'll see you all there